It's important for your app
to stay up to date in order
to get the latest social feeds,
news, and weather reports
to your users, but in
truth, syncing too often
can be the worst idea
for the performance
of your application.
My name is Colt
McAnlis and there's
one hard and fast rule
when it comes to syncing
your data over the network.
Do not over sync.
It's a pretty common situation.
The user has your
app active or maybe
it was the last app they used
and you want to make sure
that there's plenty of new
data available for them
so that they won't
close your app
or let their attention
wander elsewhere.
So you sync.
You sync a lot.
You ping the server,
you ask for new data,
and bring it down as often as
you can, but let's face it,
this is a horrible idea.
Firstly, this destroys
the user's battery
and as we've said
before, networking
is the single biggest
battery hog there is.
Not only does it drain battery
just to initialize the chip,
but then it keeps it awake for
an additional 20 to 60 seconds
after you're done with your
request, also drawing power.
In fact, you can fall into
a really bad place where
each one of your
networking requests
ends waking up the radio
and paying this cost.
Not ideal.
Secondly, consider the
sheer volume of bits
that your app is now
responsible for requesting
on the user's phone.
Now, for users on
restricted usage data plans,
this can be a make
or break crime.
One app eating of a
month's worth of bandwidth
simply because it keeps pinging
the server for new data?
Not a good idea and this
is also a double whammy
because the slower
the connection,
the longer the radio stays on
to help transfer data, meaning
that you're not only being
taxed for bits on the wire,
but also draining more
battery as a result.
So, OK, so syncing
too often is bad,
but let's be realistic here.
Your app needs the data in
order to provide the user
with the best experience.
We can't just cut syncing
out completely, right,
and the truth is
you don't have to.
There's a few handy
trick that you
can employ which
will give the user
the same sense of
functionality but require
much fewer requests.
The key to this solution is
understanding the difference
between stuff that has
to happen right now
and stuff that could be delayed.
For example, if the user
takes an action requesting
that the news feed
updates right now,
well, then you pretty much
have to kick off that request,
but really, the
second and third types
are where you can actually
start improving performance.
The requests that happen
on regular intervals that
keep things up to
date but don't need
to happen right this second.
If it's not super
important right now,
then you could be smarter
about how it's synced.
Case in point.
You should really never poll the
server regularly for updates.
You're basically just
wasting bandwidth and battery
for the server to tell you
that nothing's changed.
Instead, it's better to
leverage other services
like Google Cloud
Messaging, which
will let the server signal the
app when there's new content.
This will reduce the
amount of battery
churn the phone is
doing and reduce
the overall number
of server responses
that you need to worry about.
Now, if there's a situation
where you simply have to sync,
then make sure that you're not
doing it on regular intervals.
Remember, this wastes
resources and most the time,
there won't be new
content waiting for you.
Instead, adopt a back-off
pattern based on responses.
For instance, if no new data
is available, double the length
you wait until you check again
and if nothing's available
the next time, double
your wait length again.
This will still allow you
to sync against the data
but we'll slowly back away
from higher activity based
on how frequent the server
site information is updating.
And don't forget, you can
also adjust seek frequency
based on user activity.
For example, if you can detect
that the user is driving
or running or if the phone
has entered into sleep mode,
you can make a good assumption
that they won't need data
at the same rate.
On the other side,
though, if you've
noticed that the phone has
been asleep for eight hours
and suddenly starts
getting moved around,
then there's a good chance
the user has just woken up
and it might be the right time
to kick off the sync request.
And, finally don't hesitate
to adjust your sync frequency
based on the state
of the device.
Waiting for it to plugged
in or connected to Wi-Fi
to do syncing helps
keep the battery happy
while users are out and
about and the good news
is that you can update
your app to adopt
these patterns without having to
write a massive amount of code.
GCM Network Manager is a
Google Play services API
which helps to schedule
network-oriented tasks
and handle batching for you.
This greatly simplifies
the implementation
of common patterns
such as waiting
for network connectivity,
network retries,
and exponential back-off.
Basically all the
good stuff you need
with one single helpful API.
And if you're ever wondering
how your application is using
the network, make sure to check
out the network traffic tool
inside of Android Studio.
It will easily show you
the frequency of your data
transfers and the amount
of data transferred
during each connection.
Of course, that's what it
all comes down to, right?
Watch some videos, improve your
app, make your users happier,
but you're not done yet.
That's why you need to check
out the rest of the Android
Performance Patterns Content and
don't forget to join the Google
Community as well.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember,
perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]